[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
are there like trials or do me a favor
can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground you're the spider-man from
you too can you summon the mummy of
spiders oh yeah no no I haven't - she'll
come into the suit on that the rich and
the powerful like stark they don't care
about the world's changing voice time we
change - what is a crazy dangerous
mission traitor forget the flying
monster guy there are people who handle
this way you read the weapons Barry was
a 230 you missed it
[Music]
what if somebody died I was just trying
to be like you I want you to get better
I'm gonna need the check back well
nothing without they suit if you're
nothing about this shoot then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up they need
stuff carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything
protect my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
I don't mess with
I'll kill you and everybody in your love
guy is still out there I just got to do
this on my own
just don't do anything stupid all right
yeah
you